bonjour meriem
[Musique]
alors dites nous pourquoi vous vous êtes
intéressé aux relations entre le
président mexicain andres manuel lopez
obrador et les états unis qu'yat-il de
particuliers dans cette relation
bilatérale
et là j'ai été interpellé par le site
que le président lopez obrador parvient
à la fois à descendre la souveraineté de
son pays a rejeté les ingérences
étasunienne en amérique latine notamment
à cuba et au venezuela a exprimé sa
volonté d'accorder l'asile par exemple à
julian assange tout en parvenant à
entretenir de bonnes relations avec les
états unis habituellement pour bien
moins que cela washington traite avec la
plus grande hostilité certains
dirigeants qui lui tiennent tête mais au
mexique c'est pas le cas et lopez
obrador affirme son style sans s'attirer
les foudres des états unis quand vous
dites qu'il tient tête aux états unis
qu'est ce que vous vous entendez par là
quelles actions at il mené qui aurait pu
agacer washington
et b a déjà été fait à souhait depuis
l'ère trump qu'il veut accorder l'asile
à julian assange vous savez que julian
assange journaliste fondateur de
wikileaks est poursuivi par les
états-unis en grande-bretagne pour le
moment pour avoir révélé des crimes de
guerre de l'armée américaine en irak et
en afghanistan voilà de quoi agacer les
états unis et lopez obrador de celle de
lui proposer l'asile dans son pays
ensuite le président mexicain qui me
concerne hammam lot de par ses initiales
se rangent explicitement du côté de cuba
et demande l'arrêt de l'embargo
économique étasunien pour sur l'île
communiste qui court depuis 1962 en
septembre dernier c'est en présence du
président plus bas que le président
mexicain a encore une fois réitéré un
appel aux états unis à cesser à lever
l'embargo contre cuba et enfin autre
exemple d'insolence entre guillemets du
point de vue de washington
lópez obrador a organisé en septembre
dernier un sommet de la cemac là c'est
l'axé la communauté des états latino
américains et caribéens à mexico en fait
c'est une organisation d ela qui n'avait
plus de vie depuis quelques années eh
bien l'on a ressuscité avec comme but de
revendiquer d'affaiblir l'eau et à
l'organisation des états américains
dominés elle par washington alors
ablo veut la remplacer par aucun
organisme qui est je cite soit vraiment
au thorium et qui ne soit le lac et de
personnes à ce sommet d'ailleurs on a vu
débarquer nicolas maduro le président
mexicaine qu'on avait pas vu voyagé
depuis de nombreux mois et là il a été
invité par le réseau bras d'or qui le
considère comme le président légitime du
venezuela contrairement aux états unis
qui eux reconnaissent qu'on vous savez
les opposants soient noyés d'eau comme
président du général nous malgré malgré
tout cela lopez obrador maintien de
bonnes relations à washington alors
comment est ce que vous expliquez pousse
ta
wii bon alors la réponse détaillée dans
l'article je ne connais que nous avons
publié sur notre site avec le précieux
éclairages de christophe ventura clé
directeur de recherches sur l'amérique
latine à l'iris mais bon pour résumer de
mecs ils partagent 3000 km de frontière
avec les états unis ce pays est le
principal point de passage des migrants
venant d'amérique du sud et d'amérique
centrale tout comme du trafic de drogue
il y a en outre de très nombreuses
usines américaines qui produisent à bas
coût à la frontière avec le mexique
grâce à ses sous traitance les
américains peuvent rester un peu compté
compétitif par rapport aux chinois
puisqu'ils ont cette possibilité de
délocaliser leur production bref vous
aurez compris qu'avec tous ces dossiers
communs se fâcher avec les présidents
mexicain n'est pas trop dans l'intérêt
des états unis et les présidents
américains trainde comme byden ont bien
compris et lopez obrador aussi le
président mexicain a bien compris la
bien conscience qu'il a une carte à
jouer en termes d'affirmation de sa
différence et des leviers de négociation
de poids contrairement à ses
prédécesseurs qui était peu plus
volontiers aligné sur la diplomatie
américaine en amérique latine et bien
amelot lopez obrador se distingue et
profite du poids que tu es son pays pour
affirmer ses idées tout en restant en
bons termes avec hot chip merci beaucoup
meriem et puis je le précise à pour
aller plus loin on retrouve votre
article sur rt france pointé vers un
article de meriem la reddition